if you open
um that guide page called pde models
that's a good base for us to look at
everything okay good
okay people joining this live stream we
are talking about
pde models and um
the effort to make specific pde models
of particular kinds um
oh come on why does it do that it was
supposed to be said to not do that
so okay now we talked last time about
some things that were
not okay but i think have those been
fixed now where we were starting off for
things like diffusion term and so on
yes yes good i've added the laplacian
term
poisson component helmholtz component
and wave component
i like it good schrodinger is in the
making it's not finished yet but i'm
working on that
i like it um the vendor suggested to
also add
uh quadratic degrees um um i haven't
looked at that yet
one concern there is that um this is a
higher than second order derivative so
we can't i think them right away i think
the kdv is a mistake
i wouldn't bother with kdb i think yeah
i don't think it's
right just okay yeah good then we'll
remove that and i'll
i would put it in the function
repository or something for now
shortened you should not have an e in it
uh okay our conventions should not have
an e okay we should have an er
well i know it should happen but we
don't do errs in function names
okay same as grove now is with it yeah
yeah
you got it there um
okay so let's take a look at diffusion
term here
yeah let's skip this kind of nonsense
okay
i mean it's amusing but but i just don't
think that's a
okay i'll remove it no noise yeah
i mean there's a separate kind of page
perhaps i think it's very important for
these other ones because a modeling
language the point of a modeling
language is to bridge
real world and model world i i know i
know my understanding was that stephen
was talking about the image right not
the graphics above that
no not the graphics above that but yeah
okay no no the image is not intended to
be there that's an idea
yeah for an illustration yeah yeah i
don't
know
well okay fine i mean look i think i
think
listen i think showing what happens to a
gaussian
under the diffusion equation that would
be useful to show i mean alongside this
picture
you know show a gaussian show it
diffusion diffusing down i mean i think
that that would be that would be helpful
i mean maybe that's what you have as the
first example here
do you no that's what i want to see is
the first example okay
i want to see something where you just
start off with a you know some
little uh you know got it and then
it decays yep and and makes a gaussian
yep i also think it would be useful in
properties and relations i hope you have
in cases where there is an analytical
solution i hope you show how that
corresponds
not yet but i'll add it yeah that's
important
and i think it's also important now
presumably you can use this
actually wait a minute wait a minute
wait a minute wait a minute wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait
in case this was an analytical solution
even in the basic examples you should
show that like you should show how you
can use diffusion term
in you know desolve well that's not i'm
i need to talk to the vendor about that
because those operators are inactive
and i'm not sure diesel then he needs to
make it handle them
yeah sorry i've talked to him about that
and
i think it's in the making but i don't
know the latest so fine but but
that's an important thing to make happen
okay because that's what it means to
have a good integrated interoperable
system absolutely
we're well aware so it's been a form but
it's just not i don't know far
okay all right but i mean so it is
correct is it not
that something like this if i look at
the detailed form of this this term
right i don't know what that that minus
one thing is here why is that so
braced up that minus one
do you understand my question not really
no okay
okay this is a one dimensional it's a
matrix it's a matrix right
okay why it's a one-dimensional
diffusion equation here isn't it
so because it's a dot product it's the
dot product with the gradient
and if we have two spatial dimensions
it's going to be a two by
two matrix okay but but why isn't it
just a vector dotted into the gradient
here
why is it a matrix dotted into the
gradient
do you understand what i'm asking this
is a scalar quantity right you've
actually
been multiplied with times but if you
want to if we want to use the consistent
dot in
in all dimensions then it has to be a
matrix
wait a minute so this thing here
gradient
there is a vector correct or not okay so
a vector
dotted into a matrix gives a vector
right correct
yeah oh and then there's a div yeah then
there's a div okay i get it
then that gives the scalar result yeah
okay so i think it'd be useful to show
in this diffusion term thing here
i think it'd be useful to show this
being used symbolically
as well that is given a
just to show that if i put an e to the
minus x squared
that i get like let me just try it here
okay
so what i should be able to do is say
okay so then and then we're also
explaining some other things here so
so let's say i give this thing here and
i put in there
e to the minus x squared
okay so now it does that okay so now i
say
activate that
and i get this and now explain how this
works
i've got diffusion equation okay i don't
really understand this do you want the
coefficient to be the exponential
because you've
made the dependent variable um with the
exponential
so i'm saying that u of x the solution u
of x
is e to the minus x squared yeah yeah
okay
okay so now why isn't this working why
doesn't this come out to be just be
something proportional to either minus x
squared
do you understand what i'm saying
diffusion equation is the thing by the
time
oh maybe maybe i need oh look maybe what
i need to do
is what is the right solution x squared
over t
right and then you you need to add a t
now for the time dependent component
right
well so then what i want to do is i want
to take this and i want to say
derivative of that with respect to time
if i'm not mistaken is that correct
okay what happened here well in any case
i think you need to give this an example
i know i see what you want yeah right so
just to
show people that this isn't an alien
creature
yep this is just a way i mean
in other words okay so here's what i
think we should do right
so like for example if i were to just
take that diffusion term there
oops take the original diffusion term
from here
and i would just say you know let's try
it
let's activate that okay
and then say magnificent okay that
right there that's very useful to see
okay right
and then to say okay fine yeah
that's what i would like to see very
very you know you can see this
and then say i mean basically just put
in after that activated percent
yep good um
and similarly here you know because this
is again going to show
you know what really is that okay in the
simple case
yep right you just say
why did that and i understand that
well so um the kappa
is is um is replaced but it's uh it's a
constant
oh i see it's equal to one so if i if i
make it x
to a well if it's i see if it's if it's
position dependent for example yeah
okay magnificent okay fine
okay now what is the minimal syntax for
this diffusion term
so i have to put that x in braces what
do i what am i doing here so
what i'm putting in here what is the
what is the actual form here
so this is x
i see okay so it's the dependent
variable
and then the independent variables
correct okay
yep okay so so presumably we should
support the case without braces around
the x
for a single independent variable okay
that is what i mean yes
okay so i mean what what is really nice
about this
is let's just write out you know we'll
be saying
do you of t and x
now i don't understand why you'd say you
there because
i would expect it would be u of t and x
that we would be giving right
why are we just giving u of x here am i
making sense
yeah you can add the t um it's not
documented though because this operator
is
in principle a state a stationary
operator so you ask u
t comma x i mean
do do the comma t close
plus the diffusion term u x comma t
well comma t plus yeah
new tx yeah correct comma and i'd like
to just say comma x here but well that's
not working yet but yes
yeah yeah okay there it is and you need
to activate that again
because yeah i understand this works
fine already yeah
there you go
great great that's exactly what i want
to see i mean you see this kind of thing
particularly with more complicated
equations that's beautiful
and that we should write that out
somewhere here just say that is the
diffusion equation
yep it's very nice okay let's do that
with a more sophisticated equation
um
you could add another term for example
like a source term to make a poisson
type equation
now when you say source term there are
many source terms in the world
yep i don't think it should be called
source term yeah
what should it be called what is it in
fact so it's basically
um typically if you have an equation
left hand side right hand side it's
what's on the right hand side
and typically it's independent of the
dependent variables but
it can it's more general than that but
that's what's typically
what it is yeah so it's a it's a forcing
term it's an
inhomogeneous term yeah so vladimir on
our live stream is pointing out
that a more generic way of describing
pdes is with you know the elliptic
hyperbolic parabolic characterization
but the problem with that is as i
understand it is that there is no
you know you say okay it's an elliptic
pde
well okay so a question if you change
character
they can change character over space i
understand it but i'm asking
i'm asking the question is there a
generic parametrization of an elliptic
pde
no because the elliptic is a description
of the way the characteristics work is
it not
yes yeah well so that's we have we have
a generic parameterization of
of the pdes and that's what the you know
that's what what our
finite element method solves is that
particular generic parameter they say
i don't understand that can you make a
can you explain that
okay all of these all of these building
blocks
go into a particular second order
spatial pde say okay which is typically
elliptic
so these building blocks are to form
those things but we have that
i have what have we have a very basic
form that we solve
for the finances so what is that form um
what is a good place to see that oliver
wait a second box just says model
partial different equations of the form
and that's the complete form
so why don't we just have a
parametrization of that
oh no i understand why don't we have a
function which just takes
you know alpha beta gamma c i see
okay but but
we could but then we wouldn't have basic
stuff like diffusion term no no
no no no no no no no no you're not
additionally yeah in addition
well
okay so in fact this is a good point
okay so i mean if i trivially look up
an elliptic pde here right this is the
form
you know this just has a bunch of
condition coefficients right
yeah and
i mean i'm not sure how much it helps us
to have
i mean it saves some typing it would be
useful to have
because especially some customers have
problem with the type setting and things
like that so it's it's
like i think it would be useful to have
and i think i'm going to add it
um anyways all right okay so so let's
why don't we add it
in this form right i mean as opposed to
no just we don't know i think the matrix
is the right way to do it steve
yeah what matrix well that's that
that diffusion coefficient is a matrix
right and that generates
generalizes to 1d 2d or 3d easily
whereas
yeah okay so explain to me what the
general form is
so um basically c
is is a matrix um everything that you
see that's
a greek letter is a vector and
everything else is a scalar
so you're saying this works in arbitrary
numbers of dimensions in principle yes
but i don't understand why this thing
isn't just a a general
look if it's a linear function right
of must not be what's that
c can depend on you on the dependent
variables it must not be linear
okay but but but then it need not be
linear you mean
sorry it need not be linear yeah
but in general why aren't we just having
a thing
where i don't understand why there isn't
a trivial matrix here to give
which is am i confused no a tensor in
fact
yep and the tensor is basically just the
the components are you know
the the one the x derivative the y
derivative the z derivative
am i am i confused here and then we
simply have or is it
is it just a okay this is a second order
we're talking are we talking second
order are we talking other things
we're talking about dependent variable
we're talking matrix yes yeah
so a second order a matrix
which just has those coefficients in it
so i don't understand why we don't just
say
you know i mean
we could just say linear
i don't know linear pde
term and then what we give is a matrix
or in general a if for higher order
equations in general
tensor for second order it would be a
matrix for third order tensor
um and we just give that and then we
give we give that matrix of coefficients
and then we have to give the dependent
variable
u of x or whatever whatever it is i
don't know how that would
i don't know exactly how that works you
have x y in the same way the framework
is made so that would be
so initially we'd have the the variables
and then we'd have parameters where you
specify the sub components
well so but then the matrix then would
be there right it's just a matrix
right of the coefficients of the various
derivatives of this thing here
right okay so and how how would how
would we address
um i mean so if if so we have a vector
for
for the the conservative convection and
the vector for the convection how would
we know
where to put the vector without having
no vectors
this is just an equation that that is
just something that is doing
the generic um
uh
um you know that's just doing the
generic thing right it's just
a misunderstanding i'm just saying this
matrix
is just giving you the coefficient the
coefficients in here are the
coefficients of d
u x y z i mean so let me write it out
it's
derivative okay derivative of
you know um then that would be you know
the components the ijth component
is derivative i j of u of whatever it is
right
that's that's the coefficient of that
right so what so the whole thing is the
sum of the matrix
terms a i j this thing here
times that um and that thing
summed you know over inj
see what i'm saying that's just the
diffusion term
yeah that's only the diffusion term
stephen
that doesn't include some of these
convection in other terms
well you're saying that the the aij have
to depend on you
right that's what you're saying
in general they can no no i'm not saying
that i'm saying if you have a convection
term
it's not a it's not a second derivative
it's a it's just a first derivative
okay fine so you're saying that that has
to so i'm just saying
that if you say there's a linear pde
term then that's the second derivative
there so you give a matrix there
if you've got first order things you
give a vector there
right so you're giving vectors of
coefficients right so
the thing is the sum of the linear of
the pieces that are first order second
order third order whatever
yeah the issue is that there are and
this is not
this is not crucial but the issue is
that there are there are cases where
you know having to see inside that
divergence as i mean
you're absolutely
so this isn't the general case right
this is the case where i mean in other
words that that matrix
where where it goes whether this is
simply the coefficient
of the you know i mean this is the
mathematical form that is normally given
it's just a sum of you know various
order derivatives right
i think we should do this i think it's a
good idea yeah i'm not sure i mean
we you know in general these
coefficients can depend on the dependent
variable so i'm not sure the linear term
is the right okay well then you tell me
what it should be but i mean this is a
you're saying it's not necessarily a
linear pde
it could be non-linear it doesn't have
to be but it could be important i mean
yeah maybe maybe this this level is
appropriate for the linear case and
would you well but no you tell me what
this should be called i mean this is
this is basically a sum of components
right this is some kind of um
uh i don't know you tell me what this is
i don't know
okay but in any case this is the
elliptic pde term
why is it elliptic why would it doesn't
have to be but that that's not
so so then let's not call it that
because
um
what is it it's it's a it's a second
order term second order term
but it's not second order because you
can have any order because the matrix
can be any rank
oh i mean you see do you want to go with
that
okay you just do any rank it's trivial
it's just the same exact formula
sure pde term just
term and pd term
or tensor term
either tensor pde term or tensor term i
i
you know i'm wondering whether these
should all have pde in them
yeah so um
yeah so that would be for example
acoustic
pde component or term i think that
wouldn't be bad
do you also i think that for the
diffusion one like i think so the
diffusion pd term okay i think so i mean
i think so i think that is a because
then we have source pde term
and and we don't have a problem there
yep
okay good point i mean derivative
what do you think i think okay okay
yeah i think that makes sense because
then we then we're out of the box of
of resource term the right name because
i we can't have a thing called source
term
yeah diffusion pde term
yes that's not too bad that's fine yeah
what plus
in pde term
i mean you're not going to use it for
anything other than a pde right no
no they're very supposed to yeah i think
i think the specificity is actually
good
now obviously dirichlet condition
neumann value those are more generic but
that's okay
because those are i mean they are always
for pdes but it's okay
yeah um and all right and those
those are not changing those we
introduced no no i understand
right so it would be heat transfer pde
term
which is very good i think yeah that's
good yeah
a heat transfer pde component and by the
way this isn't model pde transfer that's
not the right
thing to use right it should say this
this is up this is not updated i think
the pd models page
i've changed that okay should i should i
get an
update leave it leave it i'll i'll fix
it
okay please let's not have cartoon
pictures like this
i mean if we're going to have something
like that are these are these hours that
we drew or yeah
yes yes
i don't like them very much i mean the
style is too cartoonish
if we're gonna have this we need less
detail in the pictures
okay so what we didn't want was there's
like a picture further down
like a like a plot oh no somewhere
it's in the boundary conditions pages
it's not not okay yeah yeah but i find
this they're super
unintuitive they're not very i agree i
this is useful to have but there's too
much this is too cartoonish
this needs to be simplified yeah
okay i mean this picture we could forget
about you know there's no flames here
there's just you know forget the hand
forget the
bubbles you know this is forget the
beaker forget the 3d beaker
just a flat beaker conduction convection
radiation
it's fine you see what i'm saying just
the virgin
this is you know i expect people to read
this that don't know what convection is
they've never heard it but they're going
to understand it i understand
i understand but this picture is too
whimsical okay
no it's borderline yeah but it's yeah i
mean it's interesting
and we should definitely keep these
pictures and we can use them elsewhere
but i think these pages should not have
those pictures on them
right they should have much simpler
pictures
right how can we communicate with the
least
sort of whimsical cartoon
you know stuff um
so the one on the diffusion um diffusion
term page was okay
it's okay yeah it's okay
i mean just skip the representational
junk with hands and things because you
know radiation
works it just it doesn't no you know we
don't need that
i think i mean we could test it on
people
if if we if we do something the problem
is
i mean i'm not i'm i'm all for trying
another iteration okay
yeah they know when we go too abstract
that we so then people stop
communicating okay but but okay just
reduce the whimsy level
sure okay what do we need to look
at next
so let me just look down here at
something like
acoustic absorbing value okay that's
useful that's a perfectly reasonable
picture
i don't have a problem with that picture
that's probably a prototype
that doesn't look fine nope that's the
that's
what we wanted to put there oh
okay so
all right absorbing value
so okay so if i take entities
you know we have a bunch of acoustic
absorption data
can i just put entities here yes can i
put
i've added a new um property up to these
models called material
and then you can and enter the material
as an entity i've done it as an as a
property of the parameters
because then you'll only have to specify
it in one place and not
at every boundary condition so if you
look at the acoustic
component at the main ref page
you'll see a new um a new
property added a little by the way this
i don't have a problem with again
i just don't like seeing hands and
beakers and things like that
okay this looks good yep good
even even the speaker there is sort of
okay
i mean that's that's sort of yeah that's
sort of okay
um go ahead what we're going to show
okay and scroll down a little bit
there's a list of properties
there there's now a new property
material and i think in the scope
section there is an example of where i
show that where you specify a material
what does the blank mean here blank
means there is no default material
then there always should be a default it
should be none or something
or automatic what is the default
material none there isn't there is no
default the default is that the density
are set to one and the sound speed is
set to one
so because density and sound and say it
be automatic
then call it automatic yep
none would mean a vacuum which doesn't
work for you yeah that's not right
um right so and if you scroll down a
little bit i think in the scope section
um there is sound speed okay so let's
take a look at this so then
here i set parameters so so instead of
parameters i could put in here
air no you cannot why not just hold on a
second
because you'd add to parameters you add
um material string material goes to
um whatever material i know i don't
believe in that yeah the reason
the reason why this is useful is because
you have several components where you
need to specify this
and power parameters is is the place
where all information is collected okay
but right here you've just got material
properties sound speed and density right
yes and you could you could replace that
with material
goes to air no i i know but why not just
put air there
because you can always get sound speed
and density out of the material
object you see what i'm saying
some but then it's not it's i mean it's
not an association anymore then it's
okay
it's okay that's a that's uh you know so
then you have a very beautiful thing
here what you're saying is
right here wherever you give this
acoustic component instead of pause
it just says i mean this is very
beautiful that what you would be saying
is
something where you would say something
like if i
go to a page here
okay
isn't that magnificent if you could just
say that
right acoustic components and not
working
still need the parameters for example
for the for the boundary conditions
so i understand but you didn't give them
here you didn't give them in this case
did you
right you just said pars is this those
are pure material properties
okay so in the cases where it just works
by chance so to speak
on a chance it's not really the right
right pudding but no no no i agree if
if you need to give other parameters
that you've got to give other parameters
and then you
say material arrow whatever and then
from material you pick up these other
things
but what you'd listed here okay so here
density of media sound speed fine what
is monopole source and dipole source so
you can
these are components or sub components
of the pde model
you can have you can add monopole
sources or dipole sources to this model
and the default is to not have them
so where do they where are they
what's their spatial position they're if
you if you so above it says the time
domain acoustic model
is this and that and then you have two
equations one for the time dependent one
for the frequency domain
and there you see f and q which are the
um
uh dipole and monopole source
respectively what's the position of the
of the monopole source for example
it can be anything i mean no no no but i
know some what
the setting for the monopole source is
just a value of the source right
that's the value that's the intensity of
that source if i say monopole sources
three
where is the monopole and then it's all
over then it's
then it's everywhere in the domain if
you want it to be a specific oh i see it
okay
yeah i got it i get it yeah yeah
something that's active is is always in
the entire domain if you want to
restrict it you need to
okay i get it so these parameters
represent
features of the whole medium so yeah in
a sense there's a medium where it's it's
it's wobbling it has a monopole wobble
everywhere so to speak yes if if it
doesn't really make sense but yes that's
what it would be yeah well
why doesn't it make sense because a
monopoly is is typically a
an object that is um spatially
constrained
i know but so how do you do that in this
case you say
if x smaller than this and that circle
or something like that then
it's one there and zero outside of it
okay so i don't quite understand why you
wouldn't be giving
i see so that's that is an if statement
as opposed to a dirichlet condition a
neumann condition or anything else
well yeah so now we're mixing things so
this we're we're not talking about the
entire pd which is valid on the entire
region directly and normal is just
boundary this just integrates
but so what i'm the point that i'm
making is what you have here
is a new construct right you have a
thing where there is a value within a
region
right that that's the constant concept
that you have here if you're having
those if statements
you're saying if x y element of some
region
which i don't think will work how would
you do that
how would you say if x y is an element
of an ellipse for example would that
work
for the monopoly yes yeah yeah yeah but
that's not how it would do it
yeah but it's not how you do it it's not
efficient would you do it
well you just you just specify the the
region
um symbolically like x square plus y
square is smaller or equal to one or
something
but why why i should be able to give it
if i've got
some complicated piece of computational
geometry that i've got
you know xy element of some intersection
of some
you know something formed from a union
of whatevers why can't i specify that
you can and but then you i mean so
stephen you
we want to be able to do this in large
scale for really large scale
problems we also want to be able to do
it for small scale problems easily
absolutely
absolutely okay we need to not forget
that yes if you want to do it for a
small cat problem you can do it exactly
the way you spent
you want to do it it works
i'm just trying to say this is not the
ideal way for large scale problems
right but you can do it tell people that
i mean okay
but but so by the way a question from
vladimir on a live stream is about
does it work symbolically and
numerically absolutely
absolutely when it can be done
symbolically we should be pretty strong
at doing it
yes so if you yes if you just um if you
in the diffusion term example on the
right hand side
if you remove the kappa goes to x or
something you'll just get a symbolic
expression
well we we have kappa well here i mean
this case here
if i that's a symbolic version as well
yeah yeah if i say d
solve percent eight equal to zero or
something
and solve it for u of x solve it for u
there
with x is the independent variable right
yep there you go okay
um
uh okay okay so
let's go back over here all right so is
there anything else
in terms of i mean i think we've been
going through
yeah i like this with the pde thing in
there i like this a lot i mean
is not the actual it's not the current
name it's source term that's an outdated
okay fine all right okay fine it's going
to be source pde term then
okay okay
now obviously it bothers me that units
aren't going all the way through here
well yeah so i've there's a small update
and so
what what's what you can do now is you
can use these pde models
with units they're going to be converted
to si based
and then going to be stripped um okay
yeah and we're working on on the stuff
for
um for making it work properly for the
for following
release but it's not going to happen for
12 2 but um yeah
you know what why don't we do this if we
had an option
that was some kind of unit conversion
option
then we could at least describe what
we're doing
that is if we have a unit system right
let's say it's s i for example
we could you know there's nothing really
in your code that really cares whether
it's
you know turning to si based units or
imperial basis absolutely not
no right there's nothing that cares yeah
correct right so if we had a
an option what do we have we have a unit
for example what you want is you'd like
to specify the target
uh the target units but the only thing
yeah
so that that's easy to okay so look we
have this option
unit system right which
which we could use which we could put in
here to say unit system arrow whatever
and what it could do i mean that would
be useful anyway
even if we're actually returning units
okay
so then what i think we should do here
is we should say something like
for now we should have unit system go
metric arrow none or some such other
thing
which means i'm not sure that's quite
the right
phraseology yeah but that would be the
default now
right which means that because in
general
we're going to have to convert to some
definite units anyway
right and and i mean unit system our
automatic
will try and be clever and look at you
know because like if you're mixing
inches with meters
right what are you going to convert to i
don't know
i mean basically but that's that's why
we have a unit system function
right i mean system option and then what
we would do is we would say unit system
our automatic
will look at the equation and if
everything is an imperial it will
convert to imperial base units
etc right but if ever but that's for the
future but for now
we can just burn in unit system i mean
you don't really care if it's metric or
anything else right so long as you have
so long as it is a valid unit system
target yeah then
you're happy with that now the issue is
how do you specify the fact that the
units will eventually be stripped
um i think that something like
metric arrow none you might want to ask
the units
team whether they have a preference for
how to do this explain what the issue is
because i think
i think then we have a you know so long
as we set this as the current default
we'll be fine you know changing it later
to just be automatic
good um and uh
yeah that's really that's really a good
thing because that way
you know that way people can give you
know
dimensions and inches and nothing will
go wrong yeah
okay nice all right
let's um let me just go back here
to look at this now let me look at
you know i haven't really dug through
the details of these i mean like like if
i go to um
um
i mean let's go go ahead look at the
diffusion term it's
it it can do complicated stuff if you go
through the examples you
um you might be intrigued i think
okay all right well let me go through
the documentation first
represents a diffusion term of that form
diffusion coefficient
c okay so you you should explain
somewhere that obviously c can depend on
x
yes it's further down it's explained in
the in the ref notes
what do you mean by in context without
pd i don't understand that oh i see
i don't understand that i don't
understand this this statement here
what does that statement mean so this
this is the form we've talked about
earlier that we're converting to okay
but when it says in context is given by
but there's an alpha and a beta and an a
here which are not being specified so i
don't understand what this is
you have to say what the alpha beta
gamma are for the diffusion case
so is is it um so this
how to ask this so um you see that part
of the equation is grayed out that
doesn't isn't enough
visual oh hell no information okay no i
did not understand that
at all god got it yeah okay so then i
mean if you put it back i'll think about
something else that's fine yeah
no no that's fine put a box around the
terms that it rapidly represents or
something
okay or put a color background or some
such other thing i didn't get it
i see what you're doing there um and um
i mean or just say explicitly you know
yeah
are the whatever i mean yeah i like what
you're doing now
i just didn't understand it yes yes good
that's why we're here
okay the um
what the hell is orthotropic i never
heard of orthotropic
well what does that mean so it means
that
the diagonal coefficients are not not
the same they vary
so the x x component is different from
the zz component for example
okay so that's like a like a a material
that has
uh you know that would be a cubic
material
wood is is orthotropic okay
but it has to be i see i see okay there
has to be orthogonal directions
that are and they're no cross terms
this is nice yeah and again the same
same thing yes understood somehow
so now in the scope section um
we'll build up complexity
you've got to show how these work with
activation yes yes we've discussed this
i'm going to do this yeah okay
fine yeah
so there now you see start to see how
things look like
when we have several dependent variables
where are the several dependent
variables so we have u and v
as two dependent variables and now th
the
yes becomes a tenza this is nice
i'm a little bit confused that you're
talking about a poisson equation here
given that there's already a poisson
term
yeah i mean i'm trying to show that you
can use these terms to build up larger
equations
fair enough
so there you go this is very nice there
you have an orthotropic equation so the
diagonal is 110. yeah i get it i got it
so it's a swoosh thing and it doesn't
say it's an e to the minus x
squared plus y squared or the alpha x
squared plus beta y squared
i mean it would help me to see that
symbolic solution i think
in these cases where there is an easy
symbolic solution yep
okay yeah good
why is it so wiggly well it's 10
minus 16. it's basically zero it's
numerically zero
i don't know really in this section that
seems wrong don't show numerical noise
that's that that's like showing you can
show that in the possible issues section
or something
okay well this is very nice let me look
at one more
some much more elaborate case maybe
convection
elaborate case okay look at heat
transfer component that's another one
i'm
quite happy with
this has come out good this is very nice
heat convection velocity
oh i see that's the convective term yep
we do not have any emissivity data yes
um i filed a bug for that so it would be
nice to so we can get it
i'm sure we can get it just just ask
somebody to get it i mean
it's it's filed as a bug yes and i've
also refiled that we it would be really
nice if we have a material data entity
um yeah that's been an issue i mean we
have material data as you know yes
but not as a proper entity and would be
nice to have that
yeah it'd be very good to have that yeah
yeah you you should
i think that's a complicated discussion
with michael the complicated stuff with
sources and so on
but i think we should be able to just
solve i mean given given what you've
done here
it makes sense to do that now okay with
without this
it's you know it's like okay be nice to
have but nobody's gonna use it
yes with this people i'd be a customer
of it you can be sure of that
yeah right so let's make that point then
and we just start
you know we may not have every type of a
s
that's fine initially but some basic
progressively
we should be able to get it yeah okay
just tell them you care
okay um but i think you're gonna need to
talk to them in person to to make the
point
yeah good and show them some of the
stuff show them why you care
yeah good okay i plan to do that anyways
for the for the units group to show what
i've done so that they can give better
feedback of
what how it could work okay so we'll do
that in one
in one go okay now i assume these names
like specific heat those agree with the
positive names they agree with the names
i've double checked that
okay good we've discussed this last time
by the way by the way
you also should allow an entity property
entity here
you know one of those entity property
objects on the left-hand side of the
association
i don't know what that is okay so
if i say
that so you should allow
in your association you should allow
somebody to say specific heated stp
arrow whatever
or actually i i don't know you need to
ask them how to do this
okay this particular this is the wrong
one because this is for an element
again you need to ask them how to do it
but i'm saying that you need to support
being able to have
because the reason you need to support
that is because you can get
an association a property association
out of
um the entity right so if i say
something like um you know control
equals tungsten
yeah okay and then i say um property
association
here then i will get
hopefully this is the prototype build so
who knows what i'll get here
but fundamentally i'll get something
like this right
yeah and so so being able to take a
piece of this
right and just feed it into your thing
would be good
wouldn't that be covered with um with
the entity anyways if i just give
tungsten as an argument
yeah it should be but i think just for
niceness you should support this case
okay
oh there there you have an example with
it with the material
that's how i see it now but but uh nice
that's not bad i mean you could leave it
out could just say tungsten will be
cleaner
okay
and so each of these would then take
okay let me just see the fanciest thing
did we get the spoon yet famous
i i remember the spoon i'll add it i'll
add it but it's
it's not there yet when was that it was
like 2010 or something
yeah it's a few years back now right
i saw oliver in germany and um
we were talking about pdes and i was
drinking some random drink
and had a spoon and it was like when
we'll be able to model the spoon
i see okay
we're getting there right i mean we're
we can't do it now it's not a problem
it's not a problem okay all right okay
that's fine
um
all this visualization all these slice
plots were basically
they will come in handy here they were
using them in symbolics too for pd's
a lot yeah this is really nice
the answer to bob's question on the live
stream is make it a data set then it
will come out
then if you if you make this thing if
you just say data set it'll display the
table
um
okay okay is there anything else we
should cover in this
this discussion um
do you want to talk about the monographs
um accompanying these
tutorials and stuff is that um that
interests you
well i would interest me yes but but are
they written
all the way so if i'm not sure it's
going to work in the prototype
look at the guide page stephen you can
see at least there's something you will
have an opinion about okay look here
i saw that i said so okay so this is
slightly non-standard
i do think it's the right thing compared
to tag them on at the end where nobody
will find them
um i know it's it's it's i'm not sure
this is quite the right style
i i agree with the principle yeah so do
you have another idea
no so the style was suggested by on t
new docs so i've asked how to do it and
that's what i suggested would be the
most uh the least invasive so to speak
it's not terrible it's not terrible
i mean i'd like to see the final design
do can i do i link to it no
not um it you you need to write right
click on it and copy the link and paste
it into the browser
into the help system sorry because this
is a prototypal it's not gonna
start directly what do i want to do
i need to go to another meeting let's do
this another time
how how long is this monograph
long like 200 pages
not that long but i don't know how many
printed pages but it's
longer than the average monograph we
have in the uh in the in the system are
we going to print them
we never thought about it i think we
should consider it
i mean would we have a decent collection
of of you know differential equation
sort of a book about differential
equations that has these people i mean
we have acoustics heat transfer and mass
transport and i plan for every
for every every physics domain i add
i'll i'll
i'll have a tutorial as well and that
explains the derivation of the equations
the boundary conditions in more detail
and all that sort of stuff and
shows um um different types of examples
than what we show in the reference pages
so i mean i have a question in in in
people's use of this
somebody's going to say i have a spoon
for example
and i'm trying to model you know stress
in the spoon
yeah whatever right
you know what we really need to give
people is is use the notebook paradigm
to give people essentially computational
essays that show
this is how to do stress analysis in the
spoon so that's in the monograph
okay no we have more than that could you
just quickly open the help
help system in here
yeah just open the documentation and
search for
pde models or something pd models
overview
this this this search system is really
driving
try to write it in one word without the
space sorry
pd models like that uh maybe that yes
there click on that
okay so this is this is the collection
of tutorials and each tutorial
has so we have a tutorial what is this
tutorial versus a monograph
a monograph so those are monographs so
and um so these are models that we have
um that are in depth of
how to do a specific model and the
purpose of this
these these new terms and conditions and
whatnot
is to replace the actual the coding of
the equation
so this gets simpler stephen with this
new modeling language
these get oh i see these are things that
already existed
yeah we wrote these first and that's
where we that's
all of that will go that's the point of
it
so people so far have been using these
to solve these things for the raw
raw equations they copy the junk part
and use that in their own
in their own notebooks that's uh that's
how they
okay and so you're saying this is being
replaced
by something that's very good yes that's
the plan for this
yeah okay and and the computational
geometry flows well into all of this
stuff is that true
um in other words i i mean everything
that i need
yes yes yeah yes and there's more coming
i mean these are synergistic
as geometry evolves it this this this
is easier to to to do pde modeling
whether you're importing models from a
cat system or you're
modeling it from the ground up and and
so on all of that gets easier over time
how long have you been working on this
oliver ten years
almost okay well it's impressive
um okay all right
and and i mean the the roadmap from here
so basically um unfortunately our
marketing department
doesn't really have information about
what our customers request their needs
so i did my own
kind of survey to to try to find out
what people want and from there i have a
ranking of
what finite element functionality is
most needed now
and that's what i'm going to implement
at least that's the plan so
those are i mean these are other domains
so you've got things like heat transfer
and so on right now and you have other
domains you're playing right so i mean
so sorry i was i was that that's a bit
misleading so i mean for
the most missing domains for physical
domains is structural mechanics and um
dynamics um i was more talking about
more general finance new finite element
functionality that i'm going to add
what's it needed for the new finance
element well i mean
what are domains so for example if i
were to do
i mean structural you know structures
and fluids
yeah clearly we need those yeah but i'm
asking the question
what i mean what are the other things
yeah
i mean like if i want to solve a black
hole merger
for example right which obviously where
the equation set up is very complicated
okay right and where you know we
actually people
do that routinely using our tools um
and you know in principle we could have
an einstein equation you know
einstein tensor term einstein tensor pde
term
you know yep i mean it's just four
dimensions and it's
it should work i think in the end
i mean in the end people are turning
these things into essentially finite
element methods
although there's some you know well
the time dependent stuff so so you have
plenty of time-dependent equations here
right yes yeah
sure i mean it's a good exercise if you
ask jose you know
he has been in the business of you know
supporting
you know solving equations in general
relativity okay
it will be interesting to see whether
you can flow through from his
exact tensor manipulation system
directly into your pde system
okay see what i'm saying i mean by the
time by the time we can do a black hole
merger
in you know in sort of you know
20 lines of code then we know we've
arrived
right i mean that uh
you know i think um
uh yeah i mean we should ask michael
trott for his
input on what domains he thinks people
are going to care about
i mean like for example in this whole
pandemic time there'd been a bunch of
pde solving with some of which done with
our tools
but the question is what domains you
know are there
are there obvious domains there i mean
speaking as an engineer there's
obviously there's other domains like
chemical um engineering
or soil engineering and stuff like that
but that's i mean you're you're talking
more about
physics-related stuff well reaction
diffusion equations
are an obvious one and we have those so
that's fine
well we do not have a reaction diffusion
term you don't have a reaction term
you don't have a reaction speed we have
a reaction term we've just looked at
that i mean
it's on it's on the reference page
what's it called
reaction term great yes
this is the reaction pde term now right
yeah well yes that's what it's going to
be renamed to you sure yeah well
great and fine a matter of combining the
two to have
what section is that under no we will
send a guide page
on that i know but where the guide page
was in very first
topic okay okay okay great all right
okay terrific that's the best answer yes
um so you should make i mean in the
examples you should make some of these
touring pattern things and so on yeah
from reaction diffusion equations
yeah i have an example for that i can
put it there sure okay
um great let's see this stuff again
or is it i would like to i would find it
interesting yes i think it'd be worth
doing one more of these when you think
it's all really final and when it's in
the head branch builds and so on okay
good and i i wouldn't mind seeing the
the monographs when they've been turned
into you know
i mean you already have the monographs
cleaned for the new design or not
that's going to take a while but i'll
i'll i can ping you before before
um release or something like that to
have another sounds good yep
great great okay very nice work good
stuff